honesty
is the philosophy
to become the most prosperous
okay so let's say if your objective is
to become wealthy
if you really want to become extremely
wealthy
the way to do it is to be extremely
honest
and the reason why the thing is that
uh there's something very important to
remember about
uh about this thing so
uh
in everything in life
there is a
log curve
so things don't go linear
they go on a log curve so what i mean by
that
and i've not done this graph before i'll
try to see if i can do this correctly
is
let's say
on this side
is honesty
okay so
less honest
more honest
okay
and what the way this graph works
is it goes like this
okay it's a log it's a log graph
and on this on this side
is trust
okay
so
if you are very dishonest
nobody will trust you
right
as you're becoming more honest
more people are trusting you but it is
not uh it is not a linear
relationship
it is a non-linear relationship so what
that means is
that
there is a
exponential payoff
at this end
it just goes off the charts
so for example
was gandhi honest
boss you have not studied earliest
you've studied gandhi in cbse okay was
gandhi honest
okay where is he on the curve
so is he over here
okay so let's say we put let's say we
put gandhi over here
okay
where is
now this is probably a difficult
question because some of you may not be
a supporter so let me let me go back in
time
uh was nehru honest
who thinks nehru was honest raise your
hand
a boss
[Laughter]
okay looks like people have some
hesitation
so it sounds like nehru is not here
is he over here
okay is he here
here
somewhere here okay we'll put nehru over
here
okay let's take mother teresa
is she honest
go where should we put her on the graph
no should we put her above gandhi or
below gandhi
gandhi
okay
all right we got mother teresa here
okay and then uh let's take um
i don't know whether you guys will be
familiar but i'm trying to think of uh
let's take nelson mandela
are you familiar with nelson mandela
where should we put him
pardon
okay so like over here
all right
so
mandela
okay so here's the situation okay
honesty is the best policy
right that's what we are taught
but that is
not the correct
teaching all your teachers who have been
telling you honesty is this policy they
are wrong
and they are stupid
let me tell you
the correct uh philosophy
honesty
is the philosophy
to become the most prosperous
okay so let's say if your objective is
to become wealthy
if you really want to become extremely
wealthy
the way to do it is to be extremely
honest
and the reason why that is important
is that
when you become extremely honest now the
thing is these guys
mother teresa gandhi mandela
they were not businessmen or business
women
okay they were like you know kind of
leaders
national leaders if you will or leaders
in a community
but if you talk about business leaders
the business leaders who get to the top
end
uh will they will not be here
they may be somewhere here or something
right because they won't you can't get
to that higher level if you're a
business leader but the thing is
that trust
is also on a log scale
so
if someone is saying the truth 99 of the
time
and someone else is saying the truth
99.9
of the time
and the third person is saying the truth
99.99
of the time
the third person
will do 10 000 times better
than the second or first person
because it goes
asymptotic
okay
so the thing is that the payoffs for
absolute integrity
are very high
okay so that's why so because the world
the world revolves around
trust
okay that's uh that's really what the
what the world revolved around and as
long as the trust is there
then
a lot of things just happen for you
and uh so that's important let's uh
uh i'm sorry who asked this question
who was a
and uh your question was about you know
the angle on dakshina right
you said no angle
is that the right thing to do
no it's a stupid thing
to have
angles and all those sorts of things so
uh so what what i what i want to do
is something very simple
i need to make sure colonel sharma is
excited about dakshina sharmila is
excited about dakshina all the team is
excited about rakshana all of you are
excited with akshara
you know like i'll give you an example
when we first started
in 2007
at that time we used to actually tell in
our forms to the kids
that on a voluntary basis
you should think of giving 10 percent of
your income
back to society
not to daksana
just back to some cause that is a good
cause okay
and we remove that we don't we don't
even talk to you about that
because i realized that it's the wrong
time
to bring up such things because
at this point in your life you can't
think about those things there's too
many problems internally with your
families and all that there are a lot of
issues going on and you have to focus on
iot and all that so there's no point
me adding more burdens on your head okay
so we we just said
that what dakshina is doing for you
is
one way help
we have no expectation that you will
help us back
now some of you help us back some of the
volunteers and different things they
help us back but we're not asking that
you have to help us back
right it's up to you
and the thing is that quite frankly that
works better
than twisting your arm
right we don't want to twist your arm
if you want if you want to get involved
and so what has actually happened is
alums of dakshna help us a lot
but they help us with time
so they don't have money but they have
time
and for us that their time is very
valuable and that works out very well so
it's a good win-win on both sides and uh
maybe when they become billionaires
whatever they might help us with money
as well but we just leave that so
i would be very stupid if i
did anything in dakshina
which would be set up to benefit me
that would be a very bad idea it would
destroy the whole
ethos of the organization
you know it's like if uh
my mother theresa lives in uh some
five-star hotel every day
then she goes and helps the poor
she will not be sitting there
right
[Music]
[Music]
oh
you